Let's talk a little bit about the trajectory,
the future trajectory of the White House Coronavirus
Taskforce.
The news is that Donald Trump is now thinking
of canceling the White House coronavirus task
force even as deaths again spiked yesterday
to 20 350 in a single day.
And this is this is like much of what Trump
has done in the last two months when it comes
to coronavirus, which is just a bad bone headed
idea.
But if your concern is just propaganda and
pretending that you're doing a good job instead
of dealing with the virus, this is exactly
what we would expect Donald Trump to do.
The task force.
I'll remind you, was formed at the end of
January.
This is the task force where Mike Pence's,
I guess the official head of the task force,
Dr. Deborah Birks, is the response coordinator.
You've got the surgeon general on the task
force.
You have that secretary of Health and Human
Services, Alex Azar, on it.
He's the one who initially put a former dog
breeder of Labradoodles in charge of the day
to day.
Dr. she's on the task force.
The commissioner of the FDA, Steven Hahn,
is on it.
Ben Carson is not just a whole bunch of people
on this task force.
Now, as it is, the task force has not been
super concerned with health and has been too
concerned with politics.
Towards the end of the press briefings, we
would see Dr. Burke's become more a vector
of disinformation than of science.
And that was a horrible thing.
But at least you had a task force that was
briefing us daily while the press briefings
went horribly wrong after the bleach injection
fiasco.
We've seen those be pared down, really stopped
at this point.
We no longer see Dr. Fouchier, Dr. Burke's
daily.
Other than in corporate media interviews.
And instead, Donald Trump has replaced the
Corona virus press briefings with these economic.
I guess I'd call them economic agitprop events
with business CEOs and other brown nosing
sycophants.
But the cases aren't going down.
So if you are prioritizing paying attention
to the data rather than whether Trump praises
CEOs, we are still finding about 25000 new
coronavirus cases basically every single day,
sometimes more, sometimes a little less.
And deaths, again, have spiked yesterday,
20, 350 deaths in one day in the United States.
A really bad number.
And when you look at what's going on in Italy,
when you look at what's going on in Spain,
when you look at the curves and then you see
what's going on here, it's not good.
And meanwhile, as I told you yesterday, CDC
and FEMA have a report which says they fear
that deaths might actually climb to 3000 a
day by June 1st with maybe 200000 new cases
a day.
Now, I hope that doesn't happen.
As you all know, politics don't play a role
in what I hope happens.
I don't hope we have one single death for
the purpose of making Trump look bad or helping
to defeat Trump.
The case for that is very clear.
There have been enough deaths.
I don't want anyone to die.
Hopefully it won't happen.
But the numbers in a lot of states aren't
looking good.
Here's Donald Trump.
Asked yesterday in Arizona about the Corona
virus task force, Trump stopped at a Honeywell
mask required factory.
He refused to wear a mask.
I'll talk about that later.
But Donald Trump again talking about we've
just done great about everything.
And at one point, he Trump walked around all
day yesterday with a piece of paper in his
pocket.
That was just a graph of the total number
of coronavirus tests, which is meaningless.
Right.
We've talked about per capita.
Here is Donald Trump's answer.
And it includes pulling out that piece of
paper.
When asked about why would you now disband
the Corona virus task force, saying, don't
you want me to say that we've done an incredible
job on testing?
With that being said, we have some additional
important antibody tests coming up that will
even blow these numbers away.
But nobody's done the job we're doing.
You need to continue to meet with the task
force to get this scientific expertise.
We will certain people as an example.
We have hospitals that we built.
We have medical centers that we built.
We have people on the taskforce that focus
on that.
We have people on the task force.
Focused exclusively on ventilators.
Well, we have more ventilators now than anybody
in the world, and we're helping France, as
you know, we're helping France, Italy, Spain,
Nigeria.
We're just we're giving, I think, 250 in Nigeria.
We have many countries that we're helping.
But the ventilator problem itself.
So you don't need that.
We have now a different sort of a combination
of safety and reopening.
So we'll have something in a different form.
But the task force for what we've done, I
think everybody out there, when they're being
very honest, I think the job we've done on
testing will shortly be and maybe even supersede
the job that we've done on the ventilators,
which people can't even believe we had to
call the other day when the governors.
So it goes on for about an additional minute.
But as you can tell, there's no answer.
There's no answer.
The question was, should you really end the
coronavirus task force?
When we are in the middle of a pandemic and
Trump says governors are happy, we have tons
of ventilators and I have a piece of paper
with a graph about testing.
It's striking me as counter intuitive to end
the task force now.
And I want to point out one other thing.
We've been watching the numbers coming out
of some of these early openings, southern
states.
The states that didn't have these are states
that weren't initially hot spots and they
insisted that they're good to go and reopen.
The numbers aren't good.
Look at just one example out of Texas.
In Texas, cases have increased dramatically
over the last nine days.
Texas had 535 new cases on April 27 that went
up to 960 new cases on April 30.
And that was up to more than 12 hundred new
cases yesterday.
Now, understand, the raw numbers are not the
important thing here.
The percentage increases are if you see new
cases continue to increase in Texas at this
rate.
There are 34000 cases will be more than 50000
cases just 10 days from now.
And by then, if the other North-Eastern and
West Coast states keep seeing declines, Texas
will have dramatically more active cases than
any of these early hotspots.
We can do a similar analysis in other states.
I hope none of this happens.
But the last thing you need right now is to
end the task force and just focus on reopening
since it's that reopening which may indeed
wreak havoc in a whole bunch of states.
Hope it doesn't happen.
What the data is pointing to.